i could chat with our guests for
hours but sometimes we only have a short
amount of time to spend with them during
the show
so here's the bonus moment we didn't
want you to miss
when i was on girls allison williams and
i had
a sex scene together and we were both
like i mean it was the first time i had
ever
done a sexy and i think it was maybe her
first time too
and we were so self-conscious about like
well everything like our breath
and our skin and like all of it and
there was a moment where she was like
i feel like we need like a lotion or
like a something
so we were like lotioning each other up
i didn't really know her that well at
the time and we were like well let's
just we'll just
well and you can do this
oh here we are you forget to put on your
robe in between takes a couple
takes and then you're like well i guess
i'm just standing here naked and then
there's always that moment where i felt
like i got really into it and like
everybody fell away and i was like okay
this is working we're transcending and
then you hear like a can
can you just move her hair can you move
her hair and you're like nope
still at work this is still awkward not
a thing yeah not a thing
i also want girls with with corey stoll
who's so brilliant who oh i
played my boyfriend for a while and i
remember there was like because i
we didn't really know each other that
well and we were filming these sex
scenes
and i was laying on top of him and we
couldn't move
we weren't supposed to like you know
they were still lighting
so i was just laying there and i was on
top of him
naked and he was naked and then saying
like
so what's your baby's name like trying
to make small talk
where'd you go on your honeymoon like
just trying to normalize it in any way
possible but
i think people see um love scenes in
movies and they think oh that must be
like really sexy and you're like no
it is the most mechanical odd
people are watching you and the best
part is i've also had that moment where
like i'm just trying to like
feel myself and i look over and
someone's just looking so bored and over
it and i'm like
oh no oh god so weird well the flip side
of that i guess is that tuck
was on um black monday which i do for
which you work on as well yeah and so we
went from playing boyfriends and boys in
the band
that he was on he played my love
interest on black monday
and we had to film sex scenes
together like so then
the whole time we were doing it i was
like does the crew just are they just
looking at me like oh so that's what it
looks like right
so so that's what they do when you work
17 18 hour days and you never see
like the outside world you end up inner
office dating
aka set man stage romance
and yeah i would like semi judge it
until i would
be like that i'm still that i there's
nowhere else i'm going to meet somebody
how do you meet people what are we going
on tinder
and that was a little bit extra for you
[Music]
you